vous ne les connaissez probablement pas
pourtant les enfants en sont fans ce
sont les stars de tik tok devenu en
quelques années le réseau social de
vidéos le plus populaire chez les jeunes
cette application des millions d'ados se
met à danser ou rejouer des scènes de
films cultes en playback des stars qui
ont également bien renflouer leurs
comptes en banque grâce à leur compte a
dit sonnerait est la première du
classement de ceux qui ont le plus gagné
l'an dernier grâce à cette application
la jeune américaine aux 75 8 millions
d'abonnés a empoché pas moins de 5
millions de dollars pour des contenus
pour le moins léger on retrouve ensuite
charlie d'amelio égérie de mode elle
enchaîne les partenariats avec les
marques de vêtements et de maquillage
au total ce sont 4 millions de dollars
qui font leur apparition sur son compte
courant sa petite soeur dixie la talonne
de peu avec 2,9 millions de dollars
premier rhum de ce classement josh
riches arabes qui fort de ses 24
millions d'abonnés et d'un partenariat
avec reebok a engendré un des 25
millions de dollars en un an
en france les deux premiers français à
être plébiscitées sont léa et lui et ses
14,3 millions d'abonnés ainsi que
thibault in chef déjà star de youtube
avec ses tuto muscu des sommes
astronomiques et de quoi déjà bien
débuté dans la vie pour des jeunes de
leur âge alors 14 ans d'abonnés alors et
d'altran cinquante mille dollars par
publication sur tic tac ne gère pas ses
contrats sur tic tac
non c'est pas mal c'est moins que c'est
beaucoup moins que ce que vous dites
évidemment mais effectivement tiquetonne
après c'est une plate forme aujourd'hui
qui rapporte quand même moins qu'un
stade g tech instagram reste leader
aujourd'hui sur les personnes produit et
mais c'est vrai que ça permet à quelques
personnes d'énergie alors qu'un stade g
tout le monde aujourd'hui peut gagner de
l'argent avec un stack avec cent mille
deux cent mille abonnés ça va très vite
aux élections de son mobilier de
l'argent oui à 100 mille abonnés bada
300 millions de vinyles plus d'argent à
300000 sa mère samira brahmia
particulier margoulins problème c'est
que c'est un bon projet mais force est
de constater que les stars sont techtoc
ne sont pas du tout les mêmes stars sur
instagram est et que c'est vrai que la
valeur est très différentes itérations
excuse moi parce que les à lui et il
regarde g
benoît chevalier aussi bon exemple on
parle de 5 millions d'euros par an sur
tik tok
par exemple le la personnel plus payer
pour un poste sur instagram
c'est dwayne johnson il le facturent un
million de dollars américains aux états
unis et s'est dit mardi sur la france
est heureux je suis d'accord montre
qu'il ya deux saisons il prend 30
secondes
al ahly poussins et fait un push voilà
moi j'aime beaucoup le dentifrice
millions $ mais ça veut dire qu'il en
fait gagner 5 et qu'il fait bon c'est
mieux si je fais la promotion pour un
dentifrice je prends les alentours d'à
peu près 3 400 euros est expliqué et tic
toc et est l'application la plus
téléchargée dans le monde en 2020
moi je vous le dis on je suis content je
suis pas d'accord parce que moi je peux
pas bouger mais faites sur octobre
c'est dégueulasse
j'ai pas fait sans décote même pouvait
bouger autre chose et demi les âmes et
les contres ou cdd les contacts instar
des personnes faut venir à la fin voilà
il faut il faut il faut s'abonner à ce
thème du masque à milan gagne quelque
chose alors mais alors non suicidé et il
parraine on sait on qu'on m'a dit qu'il
ya des comptes très prestigieux qui
n'ont pas beaucoup d'abonnés dans 10 15
milles et qui sont très suivies et
surtout qu'ils sont qui sont
prescripteurs en termes d'achat c'est
vrai quoi vraiment à ça aujourd'hui
c'est la qualité du flower qui compte ça
va la quantité et qualité paulo j'ai mis
des gens qui vous suivent et
l'engagement qu'ils ont pour vous donc
effectivement il ya des comptes qui ont
cent mille abonnés qui vendent beaucoup
plus que des gens font un million de
followers ça c'est vrai